today on the matt walsh show the leftist
media tries its best to defend the
washington post doxing the creator of
the libs of tik-tok account we'll talk
about that and also try to answer this
question why are they bothering to go
after libs of tick tock at all also
cable news pundits are now shipping
themselves off to go fight in ukraine a
win-win for everybody perhaps elon musk
exposes the overpopulation hoax a
democrat lawmaker earns props from the
left for his theatrical tearful speech
protesting a bill to protect women's
sports and as airline passengers tear
off their muzzles and celebrate their
freedom the biden administration fights
to muzzle them once again we'll talk
about all that and more today on the
matt wall show
[Music]
well if you're a pro-life activist then
you are going to see the absolute worst
of uh the other side and anyone who's
been in pro-life activism has seen this
uh the things that they scream and shout
at you and everything else talk about
harassment you certainly get a lot of
that some people on the left have been
saying that pro-life people in texas and
the other growing number of states with
a heartbeat act are no better than the
taliban because if you want to protect
babies then obviously you're in the
taliban they ignore science and biology
and refuse to acknowledge that
heartbeats are actually a good thing
insults like you're the taliban is all
they have left to say that's why our
friends at 40 days for life wrote the
number two amazon christian bestseller
what to say when the complete new guide
to discussing abortion how to change
minds and convert hearts in a brave new
world 40 days for life is based in texas
it's one of the largest pro-life
organizations in the world they have one
million volunteers in a thousand cities
in 64 countries holding peaceful 40-day
vigils outside of abortion facilities to
save lives and help abortion workers
leave their jobs you can get the book
what to say when today and if you do get
the book the very first thing you're
going to see is the forward which uh
yours truly did right and uh that's one
reason to buy it but really the real
reason is that the whole book is great
it's a great resource for anyone no
matter how experienced you are with
pro-life activism it covers the old
arguments and the new ones that you
might be hearing at work or with family
so get it now and check out
40daysforlife.com to help end abortion
wherever you live
well if you thought there would be any
accountability for the parasitic
sociopath named taylor lorenz who docks
the woman behind the libs of tiktok
account i envy your naivete and
innocence you sweet summer child the
regime will always defend its own and so
it has dug its trenches around lorenz
and and will protect her of course
now before we get to the latest on the
story and some important points that i
think need to be made about it
let's back up quickly and review for
anyone who gave themselves a day off
from the news cycle yesterday should
probably just keep that going go back
into whatever cave you were hiding in
and don't emerge there's nothing up here
for you um uh well lorenz a washington
post reporter who jins up outrage mobs
against people for a living basically
that's what she does
while simultaneously crying about all of
the online harassment she supposedly
endorsed wrote an article about the
previously anonymous woman who runs the
lives of tick tock account on twitter
she published the woman's name the city
where she lives and her employment
history she also tracked down the
woman's family and went to their to
their homes
not only that but the article in
washingtonpost.com originally included a
link which if you clicked on it
would give you the woman's current home
address
now the link was taken down after
backlash but the proverbial cat is
already out of the bag by design of
course
i mean you don't have to keep the link
up it only needs to be up for five
minutes and leftist internet trolls will
take it and run with it ensuring that
the information is enshrined forever
online
and so that was the strategy there
now the doxing is the big news here and
the most vile thing about the piece but
let's not let it distract us completely
from the fact that the articles also
along with the doxing
incredibly dishonest lorenz accuses the
libs of ticktock creator of using quote
q anon related language but doesn't
explain what that means or provide any
examples or evidence
the left has previously decided that any
outrage expressed over pedophilia or
child grooming or if you say something
like we have to save the children or
protect the children that that is q a
non-language so we can only assume that
lorenz is referring to that lorenz
starts the article with this sentence
this is what it says
on march 8 a twitter account called libs
of tick tock posted a video of a woman
teaching sex education to children in
kentucky calling the woman in the video
a predator which she doesn't mention now
what she doesn't mention though what
lorenz doesn't mention is that the sex
educator
is running a quote-unquote sex educator
anyway is running a sexy summer camp for
kids and that's what she calls it
and in the video in question where she's
t well just she's just teaching sex ed
to kids is what lorenz says in the
article
well in reality she's talking about how
she she recommends masturbation to very
young children
and she brags in the video that her
nephews were masturbating quote as soon
as they can talk we've played that video
on the show you might remember it i'm
not going to make you sit through it
again
lorenz doesn't mention any of that in
her article because she's a dishonest
soulless hack
speaking of which the piece also
contains this passage it says
tyler wrin a former english teacher in
oklahoma posted a video telling lgbtq
kids shunned by their parents that rin
was proud of them and loved them it was
featured on libs of tick tock last week
since being featured on the page rin has
been barraged with harassment and death
threats quote i've always seen myself as
the type of teacher to stand up for
marginalized voices rin said
i see fellow teachers on tick tock speak
out for our disenfranchised students and
they're getting the same sort of
harassment too
oh poor tyler wren
he's being harassed because of the mean
woman behind the libs of tick tock
account
hey just curious i mean not that it
matters of course but what exactly does
the teacher say in the video i mean does
he really just say that he's proud of
his lgbt students that's all he says huh
he just says hey uh i'm i'm proud of all
my students including lgbt students i'm
proud of you all and and that's what it
ended up on libs of tech he's getting
death threats over that
well that's that's some terrible
homophobia
if that's all he said but let's go to
the tape and find out
hey if your parents don't love and
accept you for who you are this
christmas
i'm your parents now i'm proud of you
drink some water i love you bye
[Music]
ah okay so uh he does say that he's
proud of his students it's just that
lorenz quite accidentally i'm sure
left out the part where he says f your
parents i'm your parents now.
he says this and chooses to post it to a
public platform
lives of tick tock that's another
important point here she's not sneaking
into
these people's homes with a camera
and surreptitiously recording them
she's taking the videos they record of
themselves
and post themselves and she's reposting
it to another platform
lorenz calls this anti-lgbt harassment
which is absurd because you can't harass
someone by simply calling attention to
something they chose to post but also
because she's lumping all lgbt people
into the groomer camp she's doing that
lorenz is doing that she is labeling all
lgbt people groomers
libs of tick tock is not doing that
after all you know i don't think and uh
libs of tick tock doesn't think that
every gay person or even most
believe that we should
teach masturbation to toddlers
or agree that teachers should tell
students f your parents i'm your parents
now
i don't see that as the official gay
position on these topics lorenz
apparently does and that's her issue
that's on her
but the media wagons have circled around
lorenz um
many of her peers have come to her
defense claiming that her tracking down
the name address and family members of
an anonymous twitter account it's just
good old-fashioned shoe leather
reporting
the post itself has uh has taken this
stance as the hill reports quote the
washington post is standing behind the
reporting of one of its top columnists
after a star story published tuesday
sparked pushback from supporters of a
popular conservative twitter account
uh quote taylor lorenz is a diligent and
accomplished journalist whose reporting
methods comport entirely with the
washington post professional standards
cameron barr senior managing editor at
the post said in a statement on tuesday
adding that the report quote did not
publish or link to any details about the
creator's personal life
now that's simply a lie
it did in fact include personal details
some were later removed
and some remain
one of the personal details that remains
is the most basic of all her name
now of course the lorenz defenders say
that it's uh it's not doxing to publish
the woman's name because names are
publicly available information
that's the narrative now oh it's
publicly available
well
if that's the standard for doxing
then i've got bad news we're all in
trouble because in the information age
literally everything is publicly
available to any member of the public
with the knowledge and wherewithal to
track it down
i mean your name is publicly available
your date of birth
your address
your employer
even things that are allegedly private
can still be accessed by someone who
knows what they're doing
besides do you know who who is on the
record as stating that it's doxing to
publish someone's name without consent
there is there is one person who's made
this point in the past and i thought it
did so very well um and that would be
taylor lorenz here she is just a few
months ago complaining about the doxing
campaign against a guy dubbed uh west
elm caleb
some women on tick tock were complaining
about this guy for ghosting them and it
went viral for some reason and it was a
viral trending thing
and um pretty soon this guy's name was
everywhere
and here's lorenz's thoughts about that
listen
a bunch of people are asking if i'm
going to write about the west hem caleb
story no i'm on book leave i can't keep
writing pieces for the new york times i
literally do have a lot of deadlines but
journalists who are writing about it
please speak to people with experience
in online harassment i'm not gonna lie
i've been pretty horrified by a lot of
the media coverage of this
a lot of people are just aggregating
some of the cruelest commentary online
and whipping it all up into a news story
with absolutely no comment from caleb or
nuance about the situation the top story
on google yesterday was literally this
house beautiful story that dox's caleb
puts his full name in the story zero
comment from this man
after this whole article gleefully
encourages this online harassment and
doxxing campaign they literally use him
to sell west elm furniture through
affiliate links
once again commercializing a harassment
and dachshund campaign
i think the media needs a total wake-up
call in the way that they cover online
harassment and this is just the latest
example of it and reporters should be
adding nuance not just piling on
yeah you don't want to pile on you want
to have nuance
uh the media needs a wake-up call i
agree with i agree actually with
everything she said in that in that uh
one minute clip there i agree with the
entire thing
the problem is that she does not agree
with it
she says that a a news story
dox's caleb puts his full name in the
story that's a direct quote from her
dox's caleb puts his full name in the
story
now whether publishing somebody's name
is doxing or not
it's very clear that the person who
published lives of tick tock's name
thinks that it is
now how can she justify this double
standard well
first by having no soul as covered but
second
because as always with the left whatever
they're decrying
whatever and especially when they're
decrying the way that somebody is
treated there is always an asterisk
and the asterisk says
unless they deserve it okay that's
always the exception
that's that's always the catch
so
hatred and intolerance are bad unless
they deserve it
violence is bad unless they deserve it
human rights violations are bad unless
they deserve it
doxxing is bad unless they deserve it
and libs of tick tock deserved it
she had it coming
for one reason above all others and
here's what you have to understand
this may be the most important point of
all here
if this woman had started a twitter
account called libs of twitter
and it was dedicated to the libs of
twitter her name and address would still
probably be private right now
if she had made a libsa facebook account
exposing the liberal wine moms who
populate that platform she'd be at home
safe and sound rather than having to
hide in a safe house right now
the great crime committed by libs of
tick tock was focusing her energy on
tick tock specifically
and as i said yesterday but bears
repeating the reason that this is such
an infraction in the eyes of the left
the reason why that pokes the bear so
much
is that our kids are on tick tock
not my kids my kids won't ever even have
cell phones because i love them but lots
of people kid people's kids are on tick
tock
the common thread here the theme
is that the left does not want us to see
what our kids
our kids are seeing on tick tock
they don't want you to see what your
kids are saying
that platform along with the public
school system together act as a social
contagion factory
they're like petri dishes
where the viruses are grown and
cultivated and the hosts are infected
now the boomers on facebook are getting
infected by their own mind viruses as
are the millennials on twitter
but it's most important as far as the
left is concerned
to keep what is happening to our kids in
the dark
why they cry harassment when you simply
point and say
hey look what's happening over there
they don't want you to look
while they're still sowing
they just want you to accept whatever
grows from the seed
without asking questions
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well just like the foundation of this
great country is the constitution the
foundation of your family should be your
faith and your beliefs so i have a
serious question for you if something
should happen to you or your spouse uh
who do you trust to instill those same
core beliefs and values in your children
do you think it's that the same person
the state would assign them to are you
gonna trust the state to make that
decision
if you don't have a will in place then
you have no say in the future of your
children it's as simple as that you're
choosing not to have a say and if you're
single and don't think you need a will
you could not be more wrong a will
allows you to establish who has power of
attorney over you without that the state
has total control over your medical
decisions if you can't make them for
yourself
i wouldn't trust the state with anything
let alone my medical health let alone my
children if you haven't made one yet
you're not alone though make it easy for
you at epicwheel.com when you use promo
code walsh we are so excited that
they're partnering with us at daily wire
they're protecting our staff and their
families let them protect yours
epicwhell.com promo code walsh this is
how easy it is you can secure your
future in as little as five minutes with
a complete will package starting at 119
and when you use promo code walsh you'll
save 10
epic will.com this will be the most
important five minutes that you spend
today
um let's see so we'll start here
american cable news pundit uh malcolm
nance has decided to go to ukraine
allegedly to fight the russians
and um he put up a tweet and he's posing
there with his uh you know he's got his
gun he's got he's got the fatigues on
and everything
and he captures it says i'm i'm uh
i'm done talking is what he said
and while he's been there he's been
doing a lot of
cable news hits and things and doing
interviews and talking about why he
decided to go fight in ukraine
and uh here he is on
on joy read now remember something
just last week joy reid was complaining
about the focus on
ukraine and saying that it's racist to
talk so much about ukraine yet here she
is and here's malcolm nance and let's
watch that
well as you know i spent quite a bit of
time here in the pre-war period and when
the invasion happened i had friends who
were in donetsk who were in the
ukrainian army who were writing to us
and telling us we're not going to
survive tonight we've been hit 500 times
uh you know these are graduates of
defense language institute these were my
friends and you know as the more i saw
of the war going on the more i thought
i'm done talking all right it's time to
take action here so uh about a month ago
i joined the international uh legion
here in ukraine and i am here to help
this country
fight you know what essentially is a war
of of its of extermination this is an
existential war and russia has bought it
to these people and they are mass
murdering civilians and there are people
here like me who are here to do
something about it
he's actually he's done quite a few
interviews uh while he's been
supposedly on the battlefield
and it's just a different different kind
of war i guess where you can stop and do
interviews he's been he's been tweeting
a lot too prolifically tweeting while um
on the battlefield
now
listen i i did say at the start of this
thing that if you really think america
should get involved in this war then uh
why don't you go to ukraine yourself and
fight
i did say that nance is taking me up on
it apparently um it was sort of
rhetorical i don't actually think you
should do it
um i i don't think you should go and
risk your life potentially to protect
someone else's country
it's not something i would do
and that's why when i've when i've
brought this up and i've been asking
questions about this malcolm nance thing
some people on twitter say well what
you're just sitting in the safety of
your home criticizing well yeah you're
damn right
i'm not gonna put my life on the line
for on someone else's country i'm i'm
not going to do that
and you know there are some who say well
at least we give him some credit for
putting his money where his mouth is
it's just hard for me to give him credit
though i got to be totally honest with
you because i i can't
imagine
that the ukrainian military needs or
wants help from an out of shape 60 year
old cable news pundit
who's tweeting and doing interviews
from the alleged battlefield and can't
even speak the language as far as i know
but he shows up there and immediately he
changes his twitter profile of of him
posing with with uh you know with the
fatigues and everything
and he's got the cameras falling around
he's doing interviews
is that
and and i admit i i have no experience
on the battlefield myself but
maybe someone who does have experience
you can tell me if like if you would
find that helpful when you've been if
and and again
if you're a combat veteran then i'm i'm
um soliciting your opinions on this
and i'd be very interested to hear this
when you were in a firefight
did you ever find yourself in a position
where you were thinking to yourself what
we really need right now on the scene
here is a six-year-old out of shape
cable news pundit with a camera crew
following him who's going to tweet like
did you ever think that was there ever a
situation where you were thinking that's
what we need
probably not
but this has become kind of a larping
opportunity for um for people in cable
news to show up there and get some
camera time and um
i i
i just i failed to see how it could help
but maybe maybe some
military analysts can uh can kind of
spell it out for me i'll be very
interested to hear that
this is from fox business it says tesla
ceo elon musk is willing to invest up to
15 billion of his own cash to take
twitter private and will make a bid
within 10 days according to tuesday
reports the new york post reported
tuesday that musk with a 9.1 percent
stake the social media company has
tapped morgan stanley to help raise an
additional 10 billion musk's massive 43
billion bid to purchase the company may
require
borrowing against both the company and
his stock in addition to raising money
from private equity investors the
estimated 10 to 15 billion musk is
reportedly willing to invest as well
above his roughly 3.4 billion stake in
the company sources told the post that
the co-investors will collectively have
more equity in twitter but musk will
remain the single largest shareholder so
to summarize the story isn't over yet
the board is trying to shut it down
the corrupt twitter board who again have
almost no once jack dorsey is gone
jack dorsey who by the way it's a whole
other story he's lighting the place on
fire on his way out the door
and um
once he's gone he's got i think two
percent of the company and once he's off
the board then they're not even gonna
have two percent collectively all the
rest of them
so this isn't over yet elon musk isn't
giving up but this i think is the
the uh that that's all great
but here's the elon musk news that i
really appreciate this is a video that's
gone viral today this is musk in a
recent interview i'm not sure when this
was
talking about the overpopulation
scam which is what it is and kind of
debunking it let's listen to this
yeah so most people in the world are
operating under the false impression
that uh that there are too many people
um this is not true both could maintain
a population many times it's the current
level
um
and the birth rate
has been
dropping like crazy um
so
and unfortunately like we have these
like
uh
ridiculous uh
population estimates from the un that
need to be updated because they just
don't make any sense um
really you can just look at say what was
the
birth rate last year how many kids were
born multiply that by the
life expectancy and i'd say okay that's
how many people will be alive
you know
in the future
and then say is the trend for growth
rate
positive or negative it's negative
so that's the best case unless something
changes with the birth rate
yeah he's exactly right there this is
this is a really important
thing to bring up
the overpopulation myth i mean this is
one of the most insidious
in a literal sense anti-human myths
that the left has ever concocted
and of course you always notice with the
overpopulation
myth the people that are that are out
there promoting it
say oh there are too many people there's
over we have population and
overpopulation and we're we're we're
we're
we're two we're full we're above
capacity right now well the people
saying that they never consider
themselves to be in the over
camp right they're they are just
population and then there are these
other people and then they often don't
specify who but sometimes they do
whoever it is there are other people who
uh they're
you know
they are the extras
the people that we don't need
and that's already a problem to talk
about people in that way like we're
nothing but
just sort of resources
like we're objects that you can have too
many of
and the other point is that actually
it's not that we have overpopulation
that's not the crisis that we're we're
facing
you know we're not gonna there's there's
no scenario where we are going to reach
the carrying capacity of the earth
this is one of the great ironies i think
about
uh the environmentalist movement
and over the overpopulation myth is very
much tied to the environmentalist
anti-human movement
but the people who call themselves
environmentalists and they pretend to
respect and love nature so much to the
point of almost worshiping it they also
underestimate it
quite a bit
so they kind of worship the earth but
they at the same time weirdly have no
respect for it
they they see the earth as this
tiny
little fragile thing that can be
um
that can be
destroyed and broken quite easily
who was that democrat lawmaker
famously years ago was worried that an
island would uh would
tip over because there are too many
people on it
i can't remember the guy's name i'm sure
people in the comments will remind me
so it's that kind of mentality
that you find in the entire
environmentalist movement
maybe not to that absurd level but it is
it is in fact actually just as absurd
to say that there are too many people on
earth you realize how enormous the earth
is
now sure when you compare it to other
celestial bodies like jupiter or the sun
or something
it's small compared to that
but compared to us
it's
almost it might as well be eternally
vast that's how big it is
you could take the earth is so big that
uh okay it's being put up in the street
hank johnson who's old okay that was the
guy that was the brilliant guy who
thought an island would tip over because
there were too many people on it
good old hank johnson
but you could take everybody on earth
and put them in the state of texas and
you'd have about the population density
of manhattan i wouldn't recommend it it
wouldn't be the best way to live but a
lot of people do choose to live that way
in manhattan
so the entire population of the earth
could fit into texas and that would
leave all of the rest of the earth empty
and in fact right now as we speak
most of the land on earth is empty
and i'm not just talking about
antarctica places where nobody could
live i'm talking about
places where people people could
potentially live those those places are
empty too
so we are nowhere and if the earth has a
carrying capacity we are nowhere near it
we are not going to fill up the earth
just like you you you puny little mortal
with your suv and your electricity
you're not going to destroy the climate
the climate that has
been around for billions of years
an earth that has withstood
super volcanic eruptions and
com you know
uh asteroids and comets
it's withstood all of that and then we
come along with the industrial
revolution and uh
shortly thereafter we've destroyed the
entire earth
it could endure the super volcanoes and
the comets and all that but not our suvs
not our highways it's ridiculous
um so we're not anywhere near carry
capacity the problem is actually on the
opposite end it's it's not
overpopulation it's depopulation is the
problem
um
yes the population is still growing
but the rate of growth is
slowing dramatically
and in fact catastrophically
and in many places especially in the
western world we're below replacement
rate and then what happens then
what you end up with is a top-heavy
population
where there are a lot of older people
and there's not enough young people
then you have this kind of inverted
pyramid sort of structure to the
population
a lot of older people who need to be
cared for and there's there's no one
around take care of them
we're experiencing that right now it's
going to get a lot worse in the next 50
years
that's the crisis we ought to be worried
about not have fewer kids we need to
have a lot more of them actually
many of the things people worry about
with the environment i mean it's it's
true that we've got you know you can go
and you can look at some
images and see pollution and you can see
rivers that are flowing with garbage
especially in places like asia that's
not a problem with too much population
that's just the people who are in these
areas choosing to do things that they
shouldn't do
yeah you should have respect for nature
you should just throw your garbage into
rivers like they do in many parts of the
world
the answer there is not to have fewer
people it's just to teach the people not
to do those sorts of things
and maybe rather than packing ourselves
in like sardines in the cities we could
spread out a little bit more that's a
choice we could make
all right let's go to this this is from
the daily mail it says a gay democratic
lawmaker in missouri challenged a
republican representative over their
state's transgender athlete bill ian
mackey 35 slammed chuck
bazzai 63 for supporting the save
women's sports bill a transgender
athlete bill that would remove trans
female athletes from women's sports
um trans notice they're saying trans
female now not trans woman but
otherwise known as men it would remove
men from women's sports during a debate
on the bill in the state house chamber
thursday night the representative
largely focused on uh besides family
specifically his gay brother scott who
was afraid to tell his brother over fear
that it would be held against him so
this is the um
the lawmaker
the gay democratic lawmaker going after
the republican
over this bill that would simply remove
men from women's sports or ensure that
men cannot enter into women's sports and
destroy women's sports and we'll play
some of this we might pause it midway
through but let's let's uh why this is
gone this one went massively viral and
the left loved it and calling this guy a
hero and everything and i'm sure he's
going to run for president eventually
let's listen
do you remember your remarks on the
floor last year when you brought this up
um it would you'd have to give me a
specific i mean i made a lot of remarks
sure so i recall a story you told
about your brother
okay
and i remember you said that your
brother called or that your mother
called you i believe
to tell you that your brother had some
news
that he was afraid to tell you
okay
and your brother
wanted to tell you that he was gay
didn't he
um he was uh expressing that to the
family and he thought that
that we would hold that against him and
not let my children be around him
why do you think he thought that
i i don't know i it it never would have
happened i'll tell you that
my
my kids at that that point in their life
adored my my brother
can i tell you if i were your brother
i would have been afraid to tell you too
well i would have been afraid to tell
you too this is for stuff like this
uh
when i when i first saw this clip
without context i was i was confused you
know because i'm thinking who is this
guy being interrogated what is he a a
witness on the stand what's what's
happening here right now why is this the
older guy why is he just sitting there
allowing himself to be yelled at
by this uh this little punk right here
well and the answer is no he's not a
witness on the stand he's not con
accused of any crime he didn't do
anything wrong all he supports a bill
that would prevent men from competing in
women's sports also has nothing to do
with gay people by the way
it doesn't have to have anything to do
with gay people
now the lgbt community like they want to
put that t on there and associate
themselves then that's their choice but
i don't see any reason why the two have
to be related at all
so this guy he's a gay man what does
that have to do with a man who claims
that he's a woman
what's
you explain that to me
so why is he being berated no he's not
he's not he's not accused of any crime
he's not a witness on the stand he's a
republican and this is what republicans
do they allow themselves to be berated
this is about his own family what he
should be doing is standing up right now
and saying hey you punk shut up this
this is my family it's none of your
business who do you think you are
talking about my family
maybe you should pull the will smith
move keep my brother's name out of your
effing mouth
maybe something like that like this has
nothing to do with you
then again this republican apparently i
don't know what all the context is here
but but apparently he brought up this
story it would seem
um
while this bill was being debated
because he was i i can only guess
because he was trying to give himself
street cred with the left he was he was
trying to advertise to the left and say
no no i'm not a bigot i have a gay
brother
and he thought that that would mean that
he would be uh
that they would have a less critical
reaction towards him no it's the
opposite and that's what he's go what's
happening right now
so he thought he would he would take
that story out pull that out there
to try to appease the left
and instead he's being humiliated and
screamed at by them
so the same old story over and over
again let's play the rest of this
because of stuff like this because this
is what you're focused on this is the
legislation you want to put forward this
is what consumes your time i would have
been afraid to tell you too
i was afraid of people like you growing
up and i grew up in hickory county
missouri i grew up in a school district
that would vote tomorrow to put this in
place
and for 18 years
i walked around with nice people like
you
who took me to ball games
who told me how smart i was
and he went to the ballot and voted for
crap like this
and i couldn't wait to get out
i couldn't wait to move to a part of our
state
that would reject this stuff in a minute
i couldn't wait
and thank god i made it
thank god i made it out and i think
every day
of the kids who are still there
who haven't made it out who haven't
escaped
from this kind of bigotry
gentlemen i'm not afraid of you anymore
because you're gonna lose you may win
this today but you're going to lose
oh shut the hell up shut up i'm not
afraid of you anymore
how many times he practiced that speech
in the mirror
and it just kills me this guy is just
sitting there taking it
you are so in the right
if they're republican in this exchange
you could not possibly be more right
about something
your position is that males
should not compete with everyone on
earth agrees with you except for like
five people
it's it's this guy and then the rest of
his of the democrat weirdos and they're
the only ones who disagree everyone else
is on your side everybody in the world
in the history of the world
agrees with you
it would be hard to have um
more people on your side than you do and
yet you just sit there
like a scolded child he's talking about
your family
what business is it of his
and you just sit there taking it
how about you stand up and say hey hey
listen shut up okay i don't have to
listen to you
why don't you why don't you answer some
questions like first of all what's a
woman can you tell me that you answer
that question and then maybe i'll let
you continue your little speech talking
about my brother which doesn't concern
you
what you think that quote trans women
should compete with sports because they
are women is that what you think what's
that mean how are they the same as women
are you actually gonna do you take the
position that biological males do not
have any physical advantages over women
in sports is that actually your position
literally all of the science the
entirety of modern science stands
against you and that's your position is
that really your position why don't you
explain that instead instead of giving
me a stupid little speech
about how you were afraid of bullies in
school i don't care about that
you know what you're an adult now you're
a grown man get over the bull
we were all bullied in school we all
went through it get over it now
because what what the actual concern
here is that um there there are
currently you're an adult now you're not
in school anymore
there are actually kids in school right
now
who we do have to worry about protecting
okay you still have your feelings here
because you were bullied in school
allegedly
what about the
girls in school
who don't want to be forced
into a locker room with naked boys
what about the girls who are being
sexually assaulted and raped
by boys
in female bathrooms as has happened
so that's what that's what we're
concerned about
so why don't you flip it around and put
it on him
just sitting there
kills me
but you deserve it i mean this guy
whoever that guy is he's just he's a
that clip right there is gonna live
forever and
and uh
he's sitting there as a as a scolded
schoolboy
and you deserve it if you allow yourself
to be put in that position
by somebody who could not
possibly be more wrong
he's just wrong
right down to the very core of this
issue he is wrong about it all he could
not be more wrong
all right what else we got here
one other
quick thing maybe quick this is from fox
59 in indiana says the anderson
community school corporation is
reviewing its use of an indian
at its mascot following uh as its mascot
following backlash over a viral video
posted a tick-tock the video shows two
students dressed up as an indian chief
and an indian maiden performing a
ceremony with a pipe and then a dance
before a basketball game
sarah holba who shot the video
and posted it to
yes tick tock of course says it was
disappointing but not surprising that it
was happening
hobo was attending the game and recorded
the video she posted it on tick tock
where it's been viewed nearly a million
times hobo said the anderson student
section got really into it you had the
pep band playing i asked the people
around me who said oh anderson has been
doing this forever
the video prompted backlash towards the
school district so much so that the
district put the pre-game ritual on hold
okay uh so it's a pre-game ritual it's
out of high school a basketball game and
they've got an indian mascot
and she has the video that she put put
on tick tock and let's first of all
let's watch this
this event this incident
i literally hate indiana
[Music]
in the middle of warm-ups and all
[Music]
it's
all right
there you go got the kids dressed up
as indians
good that's the mascot of the school um
yeah i got news for you i know this is
uh heresy he blasted me these days but
there is nothing at all offensive about
that it's not offensive it's not at all
offensive it is perfectly fine i will
say this on the record
it is perfectly fine for uh a white
person to dress up like a you know a
traditional indian and that's perfectly
fine there's actually nothing it's not
offensive why why is it offensive so you
can't explain it's just supposed to be
self-evident well of course it's
offensive why
because it's
cultural appropriation what does that
mean
so it's something from another culture
and so you can't participate in it or
pay homage to it or why
why exactly
like everything else on the left they
can't answer they can't answer any
questions they especially can't answer
the why question it only takes like one
or two why's before the whole thing
breaks down
that's offensive why because cultural
preparation okay why is that offensive
uh because
that's it that's all they got
so there's nothing offensive about that
and also
um
and again like it's
if
if the people involved and the people
who
made the mascot in indian to begin with
if they hated
indians
and thought they were weak and stupid
and inferior or whatever else
then you wouldn't use them
as your mascot
the whole point of a mascot is that this
is something strong and formidable and
like that's the whole point
you don't take something that you hate
and have a low opinion of and feels
inferior and make that your your mascot
so it is a tribute to
and yes there is nothing racist about
paying tribute to
um
this culture
and the other thing is that this school
has been doing this apparently for 50
years
and nobody in the school except for this
one girl cared but she even says herself
like everyone's into it no everyone's
having a good time everyone's into it
no one has a problem with it
and uh but she puts it on tick tock and
then a lot of people who are not at the
school and who this doesn't concern them
now they're offended and so the school
of course pulls it down and says well we
put it on hold we've been doing this for
this is a tradition
for i think like half a century a
tradition everyone at our school is cool
with it they all think it's great
uh nearly everyone
but some people in tiktok complained so
we're just gonna put it all on hold this
tradition for 50 years we're going to
abandon it
some more cowardice
common theme here let's get to the
comment section
[Music]
who's to blame
it's a sweet baby gang
uh here's a message that was sent to me
matt the prank you pulled with your
children is actually horrifying and i
think less of you as a father because of
it well that's a little harsh isn't it
and like i told you it wasn't my fault
it was my kid's idea
blame them
what am i going to do tell my
eight-year-olds not to do something
that would be intolerant and i don't
believe in intolerance
the honest truth is and like i got
i got mixed reviews on the uh the prank
which if you didn't listen to the show
yesterday i don't know why i'm even
repeating it now but uh
my kids pulled a prank on my wife where
they she was at it she was out you know
for a few hours and they decided that um
when she came back they wanted to make
to pretend that my daughter julia had
been terribly injured and like first of
all when i explained it it sounds a lot
worse than it was um there's no way to
explain it that doesn't sound horrible
which maybe should tell me something but
it doesn't
so they wanted to pretend that she got
terribly injured and i did say to them
you we probably shouldn't
do this i don't think
mom's not going to find this funny and
they really wanted to do it so then i
said okay if you're going gonna do it
then we've got ketchup in the in the in
the refrigerator you could use that make
it look like blood that's all i said
and uh they chose
to to go forward with that
and they just made it look like they
they made it like she got some kind of
facial injury that's all and so she was
like bleeding profusely from her face
and then my wife came home and she
walked in and she was you know pretty
horrified and quickly she was told the
truth and she didn't find it funny um so
that's that's what this is referring to
but my point is why am i not a horrible
person well number one
because i'm blaming my my kids for it
number two
because i was actually this was a it was
kind of a moral crisis for me
i was i was really i i kept like i know
that i should probably tell them not to
do it or maybe i should i could also
text my wife and tell her that they're
gonna do this
and give her a warning or something but
then i also just thought i can't like
like i said yesterday
i can't allow myself to interfere with a
good prank i i can't do it
and so that was the moral dilemma that i
was i was wrestling with it
i really
was and i think i came down on the on
the ethically correct side of this
which is that you do not interfere with
the prank
never under any circumstance
um
all right
sliver says i've been filing my own
taxes for over a decade it used to be
free and take an hour or so this year it
took two days and cost me several
hundred dollars also these people
believe that they can print infinite
amounts of money without consequence
so what exactly do they need our taxes
for
um yeah and it just keeps getting worse
and worse or worse i mean originally
there was not an income tax and then
there was an income tax it was supposed
to be temporary and then it wasn't
temporary and then and then you know um
in the early days it was just the income
tax and you had to pay your income taxes
and then they came up with the
withholding system which is where they
get to go very nice for them and take
the money from you first and then give
you whatever leftovers and then and then
if they take too much then at the end of
the year they can return the money to
you without interest and then everybody
will celebrate and say i got all this
free money no that's your own money
dummy that they took you could have that
as a savings account you you'd make a
little bit more interest on it at least
put it under your mattress you'd be
better off
uh and the withholding system was
supposed to be temporary and then it
wasn't and it was permanent um
and it just keeps getting worse and
worse and but you know it's the old uh
boiling a frog thing
where people tolerate it you know if you
had gone from you if you went from zero
to a hundred
and you went right from there's no
income tax at all to
uh the situation we have right now
peop there you would it would have been
it would have been a rebellion people
would have revolted
violently
um
but because you just do it kind of
gradually over the course of a century
or so
people tolerate this totally intolerable
situation
where our money is being taken from us
in this
and and you know
we we are burdened by this tax code that
is so complicated that you have to hot
you have to spend your own money and
hire people to sort through it for you
and if you try to do it yourself it'll
take two days to do
let's see
devon says matt while i agree with
everything you've said about income tax
you missed a big part that only furthers
your point you say the government could
run off two trillion but if we weren't
taxed on our income we would spend far
we would spend far more money thus
increasing sales tax the government
probably wouldn't even notice much of a
difference in their income yet we would
have far more purchasing power lower tax
rates promoting spending which increases
tax income yeah if you really want an
economic stimulus how about that give
let people that's that's the kind of
economic stimulus that i have supported
this whole time
including during the covet lockdowns
that's one of the reasons that's one of
the ways you knew that the they weren't
serious about the stimulus and trying to
stimulate the economy because they were
really serious about it they would have
suspended the federal income tax let you
keep your own money
you want to stimulate the economy how
about that you don't have to give people
anything just let them keep what they're
making
if you can imagine that
and then yes
despite
what many people seem to think if you
get rid of the income tax it's not that
the government all the way goes all the
way down to zero dollars
and the point you make here is very good
because yeah as it stands right now
get rid of the income tax and the
government's still left with two
trillion dollars in revenue every single
year from all the other taxes and
consumption-based taxes and everything
but actually more than 2 trillion
because now people have more money and
as people are inclined to do they're
going to go out and they're going to
spend more and then you're going to make
that money back in
income taxes or rather in sales taxes
dom says you and carton arcs should do a
special together that would be amazing
that's actually a great idea
it's not very often that i find great
ideas in the youtube section but a big
supporter of carton arcs that's the
channel on youtube where they just go
around harassing people for
harassing and publicly shaming people
for leaving their carts and parking lots
and that's a that's one collab that i
would uh very much be into
if you haven't visited my collection the
online dw shop it's high time that you
do not only should you be wearing your
loyalty to yours truly on your sleeve
you can now get 30 percent off my
collection for one day only and that day
is today 30 off i'm very generous this
is a i have the power to put these deals
in place and take them away so i'm
giving you one day you can grab your
what is a woman merch uh secure pieces
on my limited edition and highly sought
after patch program or show off your
preferred pronouns aka my preferred
pronouns handsome brilliant with one of
my best selling shirts
and there is so so much more just go
fill up your cart and get 30 off for one
day only with code swag shack at
checkout thank you for your compliance
it is truly appreciated and in fact
demanded now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
today for the final time we cancel the
mask nazis or perhaps in fact not for
the final time um after the hero judge
in florida ruled that the cdc's mask
mandate was unlawful
i said on this show yesterday that the
bite administration would complain about
the ruling but they wouldn't challenge
it
after we've all seen the videos you know
of air passengers cheering over the news
of the mass mandate ending like it was
the fall of the berlin wall
you know challenging the ruling
potentially overturning it would be
politically suicidal especially heading
into midterms but i may have
underestimated this regime's penchant
for doing politically suicidal things as
the daily wire reports today the buying
administration will appeal a court
ruling by a u.s district judge who ruled
monday the administration's national
mass mandate on public transportation
was unlawful
quote the department of justice and the
center for disease control and
prevention
disagree with the district court's
decision and will appeal subject to
cdc's conclusion that the order remains
necessary for public health
the department continues to believe that
the order requiring masking in the
transportation corridor is a valid
exercise of the authority congress has
given cdc for to protect public health
this is an important authority the
department will continue to work to
preserve
well this is why you shouldn't listen to
my predictions on this kind of thing it
turns out that i'm still somehow too
optimistic to be a reliable political
prognosticator
now i still suspect that this appeal
will be mostly for show
but maybe not
perhaps the democrats figure they've
already got so many nails in the coffin
that they might as well add one more
heading into the midterms
if they succeed in forcing masks back
onto people's faces it will be
wildly unpopular with normal people but
at least the media will feel good about
it speaking of which here's andy slavitt
on msnbc last night expressing his
disappointment over the judge's ruling
listen
we're seeing today people have to react
to i'm going to get on a plane
in about an hour
thankfully i'm vaccinated and boosted
and have a good quality mask so should
feel she'll feel reasonably good
but you know i think usually we would
like to see the cdc which has the
authority to make these decisions make
this decision
not not a judge
the cdc has asked for 15 more days to
review data uh i think it's it's
important that we we see that we have to
remember there are cancer patients and
four-year-olds that are not vaccinated
or are vulnerable
uh so hopefully
people will continue to to show good
judgment and protect themselves and
protect others where possible
oh the cdc only asked for 15 days well
okay then
i mean if we've learned anything over
the past two years it's that 15 days is
just 15 days when they say 15 days they
mean it we all know that
that's the great lesson of the pandemic
it's just that you have to keep in mind
that the word day is is relative
now we might think of a day
as 24 hours but that's just from the
perspective of earth on venus for
example a day lasts 5 832 hours or about
243 earth days what the cec and our
other public health authorities forgot
to mention is that when they say 15 days
they're referring to venus days not
earth days
simple miscommunication is all i'm glad
andy slavitt could help clear that up
for us
another cable news pundit roland martin
is having an even harder time with the
news this is what he tweeted yesterday
he says i don't give a damn about what
some grossly unqualified donald trump
judge said i'm double masked and wearing
goggles on this nashville to dc flight i
had coveted in december y'all can kiss
my ass about me not wanting it again and
any fool saying they don't matter is a
damn liar
you have to love the hat that says
roland martin unfiltered
which is on top of
a head covered in goggles and two masks
some irony overload there
to honestly though if i knew that this
fruitcake was flying out of nashville
and his mask and goggles yesterday i
would have gone to the airport and got
on that plane just so i could sit next
to him and cough and sneeze for the
entire flight
for his own good of course
now now look this may seem like just a
bunch of virtue signaling from martin
but it's actually not i mean it's not
merely virtue signaling anyway the fact
is that this man like so many others on
his side of the ideological fence
has been psychologically disfigured by
two years of coveted fear-mongering
he's still not scared enough for his
health to you know go on a diet i mean
he's not going to panic that much
but he is legitimately afraid to go
bare-faced on a plane i believe that his
fear and paranoia and effeminate
cowardice are all real
granted there are people on the replies
to his post
uh you know to this tweet posting recent
pictures of him at large public events
without a mask and saying that he's like
a hypocrite
but this is all part of the broken brain
syndrome that is incoherent and
arbitrary risk calculation
that's one of its most prevalent
symptoms
and i think nothing quite captures the
damage done to people by two years of
coba hysteria
like this short clip taken on a jetblue
flight right after the announcement
about the mass mandate was made
you could see the flight attendants
ripping off their masks and and
literally dancing for joy
and that's all great but listen to what
one of them says it's very interesting
listen
this is the kind of speaking um
right now
all night jeffree will
required a mask
oh my gosh
look at my face i don't even know how to
change it
oh my god yay
[Music]
um but please don't throw them on the
floor because you have to clean out
in just a moment
so she skips down the aisle waving the
mask over her head feeling justifiably
elated and joyful and she says look at
my face i have a face
now that might seem like a joke but
there's actually something quite
profound in that statement i think
because by far the most terrible and
oppressive thing about masking
was not how uncomfortable it was
or what a ridiculous charade the whole
thing was
but rather the fact that the mask turns
you into a faceless automaton
the mask is dehumanizing
and this is especially the case for
workers in the service industry who were
turned into a literal faceless servant
class
forced to muzzle themselves like dogs
and become anonymous
depersoned serfs over the last two years
on planes everybody was in that position
we've heard so much about the epidemic
of violence and fighting on planes over
the last two years and i'm convinced
that this explains why it's not just
that people were annoyed and on edge
about the masks but that when you put
people into a high stress situation
in a confined space with each other
and you cover everybody's faces so they
can't fully see and appreciate and
encounter each other's humanity
you end up with exactly the chaos that
we experienced
people need to see each other
and be seen by each other this is not a
want or a desire or a nice luxury
but an actual human need
because we are all human beings after
all
we were born with faces and with the
natural inclination to connect with
other humans primarily through facial
cues
the first thing a newborn baby does is
look at and study his mother's face and
it's quite amazing to behold as i've
seen
four times
that a baby comes out of the womb
already
knowing kind of where to look
baby doesn't know anything else but he
will look at your face
we are literally born with this instinct
this ability this need to see and
recognize faces
remove that from people for a prolonged
period of time and you're depriving them
of something that is so
essentially human in a deep and primal
sort of way
the writer jonathan franzen wrote an
essay back in the 90s complaining about
the very new trend at the time of people
walking down the street talking on their
cell phones
and he didn't like it very much and he
said quote
all i really want from a sidewalk is
that people see me and let themselves be
seen
now perhaps because of our cell phone
addictions we had got accustomed to not
seeing and being seen by other people
even when we're standing two feet from
them and so the masking for some wasn't
much of a stretch
they weren't losing anything that they
hadn't already effectively lost
but that just means that if the masks
didn't bother you it's only because
you'd already despaired of your humanity
so the people that brag about oh it
didn't bother me much
that's because you're sick you're a sick
person psychologically and emotionally
and spiritually
if it didn't bother you it should bother
you
it should bother you to not have your
face scene or be able to see other
people's faces
if it doesn't it's because you'd already
given up on some of the most crucial
aspects of being human
there's a reason why leftists in
particular are so comfortable in masks
it's because their ideology puts them at
war with human nature at every turn in
every way
they deny everything that's natural and
good and healthy
they want to take everything that is
true and human away from us
they even want to take away our faces
as i watch some of these videos of
people celebrating
the perhaps temporary unfortunately end
of mask tyranny i thought about another
writer c.s lewis
who wrote a book called till we have
faces
now the title refers to faces in a
spiritual sense but that's partly
because c.s lewis prophetic as he was
never imagined that he would that we we
would live in a world where our actual
faces are taken away
at the very end of that book lewis
writes this
he says i saw well while the gods do not
speak to us openly nor let us answer
until that word can be dug out of us why
should they hear the babble that we
think we mean how can they meet us face
to face till we have faces now this is
obviously meant to be understood in a
very spiritual and poetic sort of way
referring to the true self-knowledge
that comes from surrendering oneself to
god
but in modern times
till we have faces takes on a
frighteningly literal meaning
to take off the mask is to have a face
an identity it is to in many ways
reclaim your humanity
and that only sounds like an
exaggeration to people who have already
given up on theirs
and in the end
is those people who are canceled
we'll leave it there for today thanks
for watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo vadosky
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike cormina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
22.
john bickley here daily wire editor in
chief wake up every morning with our
show morning wire where we bring you all
the news that you need to know in 15
minutes or less
join me and my co-host georgia hal for
daily coverage of all the biggest
stories on morning wire